five outstanding directors all
first-time nominees have crafted five
memorable films motion pictures of skill
and imagination that show every promise
of standing the test of time for Best
Director of the year the nominees are
Chris Noonan for babe Mel Gibson for
Braveheart Tim Robbins for dead man
walking Mike Figgis for leaving Las
Vegas michael radford for ilpo steno the
postman and the Oscar goes to Mel Gibson
for Braveheart
oh I don't write speeches but I would
like to thank a few people and and I
have it on a list not a long list not
too long anyway it's there I mean I'd
like to thank the Academy first of all
I'm Alan Ladd jr. who and and Randall
Wallace who first came to me with the
script Randy wrote it laddy was attached
as a producer and they had no problem
with with giving the reins to a fiscal
imbecile you know this takes real
courage my production company had icon
Bruce Davey Steve mcaveeney Dean lopata
my right-hand man and everyone had icon
paramount and Fox who both went in they
double dipped the Sherry Lansing John
Dalton Barry London Peter Chernin bill
mechanic Jim gianopolous
it's one of the best cast and crew's
I've ever worked with John toll who's
already been honored here tonight Tom
Sanders Charles knows Steve Rosenbaum
David Tomlin thanks for dragging me
through the mud sometimes james horner
mick Rogers Simon Crane and the clan
Wallace we mustn't forget the clan
Wallace Nigel Sinclair ed Lamont Oh
Geoff Berg Allen near abroad Lurie my
wife and family for indulging me and God
for indulging me in this tiny moment and
every director I've ever worked with
they were my film school and now that
I'm a bona fide a director with it with
a golden boy I well like most directors
I suppose what I really want to do is
act but uh
that right
thank you from the bottom of my heart
this is a truly wonderful evening for me
thank you